[Musique]
avril 2015
aéroport de Montréal
je suis pas en train d'arriver je pars
je fais une sorte d'immigration inversée
en laissant derrière moi ma femme et ma
fille pour retourner dans mon pays
d'origine la Côte d'Ivoire
alors certains me dirait mais c'est
quand même le passeport canadien on a vu
des gens mourir dans les océans ou même
dans le désert pour avoir une vie
meilleure en Occident et toi tu as ce
passeport canadien
tu es canadien
et tu laisses tout ça pour venir dans un
pays qui sort des crises qui encore
vacillant
est-ce que peut-être que le fameux froid
canadien t'a gelé le cerveau
mais non tout au contraire mon pays
d'adoption m'a appris beaucoup de choses
et il m'a forgé aussi
je me suis battu là-bas
en disant
j'ai même réussi à devenir enfin papa à
l'âge de 45 ans
ensuite le Canada m'a permis de savoir
qui je suis il m'a donné ma fiche
technique j'ai eu un coach en entreprise
pendant qu'il m'a suivi pendant 6 mois
et qui a fini par dire monsieur vous
avez des sens de la famille
vous êtes innovant
et
vous êtes celui qui pouvait faire
quelque chose même si les autres ne vous
comprennent pas donc la moitié des gens
qui vous comprennent pas c'est tout à
fait normal et donc je décide de laisser
ma famille et de rentrer au Canada en
Côte d'Ivoire
voilà une partie de l'histoire
mais pourquoi est-ce que je suis rentré
mais parce que j'avais déjà été formaté
je ne suis pas venu au Canada tout petit
l'entraide l'amour le respect du
prochain
la bienveillance la bienveillance
c'était ça que vous avez appris dans
notre vie
et là je rencontre un pays où j'adore
mais il y a quand même quelques valeurs
que je n'arrive pas à bien assimiler
l'individualisme pousser
on se dit pas bonjour
alors je me dis je me sens pas à l'aise
donc vous comprenez comment voulez-vous
que je sois heureux juste de façon
nucléaire avec ma fille et ma femme et
pendant ce temps de l'autre côté de
l'océan ma mère a encore les genoux
fléchis en train de prier oui
son fils son ultime fils lui aussi il
allait au Canada il va réussir à faire
devenir améliorer son niveau de vie lui
elle et ses petits-enfants elle qui a su
utiliser son pouvoir que lui conférait
le système matrilinéaire pour s'occuper
des 27 gosses qu'on laissait son frère
lorsque celui-ci décéda dans les années
67 et qui a réussi de façon très
significative à apporter une
canalisation une éducation à ses enfants
et qui s'est rendu compte en cours de
route que finalement le monde a changé
c'est devenu moderne on étudie doit rien
tu n'es que notre tente si tu as sauvé
les autres sauf toi toi-même
et quand il se retourne
elle se rend compte que finalement elle
a oublié ses propres enfants ces cinq
enfants c'est déjà presque trop tard
la première est déjà partie en laissant
derrière trois enfants
le premier
[Musique]
après quelques escapades d'aventure est
revenu complètement comme une loque
humaine il ne peut plus prendre décision
de décision et donc c'est un éternel
assisté qui finit par nous quitter aussi
dans l'anonymat
son deuxième fils mon frère est né qui
s'est jamais retrouvé depuis l'âge de 10
ans où il a été parachuté de Cocody
jusqu'à 400 km dans les années 70 à
l'intérieur du pays et qui n'a pu être
lui-même à finir sans donner des détails
sombrer et nous quitter aussi dans les
années 2006
après avoir laissé derrière lui un
enfant il ne lui reste plus que deux
enfants
sa dernière et moi nous avons eu la
chance d'avoir un encadrement parental
paternel elle elle est professeurs de
d'Allemagne et il a une famille et la
saison 3 ils vivent bienheureux et il ne
reste plus que son ultime fils
sont seul espoir qui suis-je donc
[Musique]
je suis Jean-Marc Bini mais à Cocody
dans les années 64 dans un des quartiers
les plus huppés d'Abidjan qui quand j'ai
su que j'étais vivant le combat avait
déjà commencé mon frère venait juste
d'être parachuté à 400 km et je voyais
plus l'amour maternel je voyais pas de
visage de ma mère mon père était déjà
remarié et je sentais la situation très
palpable elle était très tendue mais
j'avais quand même une joie de vivre je
n'avais même pas le temps de savoir ce
que c'est que la rancoeur ou le mot
souffrance l'école était pour moi mon
arbre de paix et j'étais tellement mince
j'étais malade que on m'épargnait mais à
l'école je vivais je courais des enfants
me regarder mes amis j'étais tellement
mince que ils avaient l'impression que
j'allais me casser quand je te bénisse
mais j'étais vivant j'étais heureux je
savais que je comptais par la société et
puis quand j'ai eu mon certificat
d'étude primaire là la situation est
devenue très électrique il fallait
trouver une solution
l'amour d'un père ou son fils la mousse
subtile
alors un de ses meilleurs amis dit
écoute moi je vais lui prendre avec moi
je viens d'être affecté quelque part en
brousse là il va être avec moi donc vous
voyez comme mon frère et il va avoir de
quel bois que je me chauffe
et puis on est parti et qu'est-ce que je
trouve la petite maison dans la prairie
un jardin a perte de vue une grosse
villa pour deux personnes j'ai ma propre
chambre j'ai mon climatiseur on a un
chef cuisinier de catégorie 5 le matin
quand je l'ai dit Monsieur qu'est-ce que
vous voulez manger ce matin je vais vous
faire des crêpes pour que c'est ça ma
souffrance et là j'étais en contact avec
la nature et au retour de la barre après
un an mon père court sur coup me prend
et il me fait découvrir
et de façon fraternelle entre les
Ivoiriens et les Français il y avait pas
encore les écoles françaises qui
existent comme maintenant et nous voilà
partis à travers la côte d'ivoirement
Yamoussoukro San Pedro on découvre tout
ça je deviens même le chargé de mission
et puis arrive coup sur coup
90 les états l'état ferme les banques
ivoiriennes les banques d'État un
premier coup le temps de me ressaisir et
ben le fromager est tombé mon père nous
quitte et voilà c'est la descente aux
enfers mais je me ressaisis et je me
rends compte que Dame Nature est
toujours là à côté de moi et cette
fois-ci c'est des amis qui s'approchent
de moi en me disant mais on a des amis
entrepreneurs en général qui sont des
expatriés eux qui ont décidé d'aller
dans la nature souffrir faire des
orientations des des bivouaké et tout
pendant 5 nuits et 6 jours est-ce que tu
veux participer je dis oui et là je me
retrouve encore dans mon élément dans la
nature et je le fais tellement bien que
je touche à tous les postes de
l'organisation et je finis par être
intendant et l'un des responsables me
demandent de travailler avec lui
et c'est là que je prends une nouvelle
connexion avec ma mère je la voyais de
temps en temps mais cette fois-ci je la
rencontre et je la rencontre je la vois
toute maîtrise mes dignes
[Musique]
elle avait déjà fait ses analyses sa
première fille déjà est partie et là je
me rends compte que Dan mature a
toujours été ma mère pendant toute cette
période où ma mère était absente et il
Dame Nature fait la passation avec ma
mère et elle elle me regarde et comment
ça me peaufiner à m'enseigner la nature
la culture à me donner les règles de
base à m'expliquer le pourquoi j'ai
compris enfin que elle-même toute petite
son grand frère il avait récupéré à
l'âge de 3 ans lui qui était
suffisamment âgé et que c'était un
devoir pour elle de s'occuper de ses
neveux
et donc je la comprends et qui suis-je
pour elle je deviens son assurance
maladie sa pension de retraite
sont pourvoyeurs et elle elle est
l'éducatrice
des petits enfants qui a laissé ceux qui
sont partis
et de ses petits-enfants de Saint il ne
reste plus que trois mais
nous travaillons ensemble tout se passe
bien et c'est dans ce cadre là que
j'étais dans cette résilience et que je
me retrouve par des concours de
circonstances au Canada mais pourquoi
avril 2015 je rentre mais je me rends
compte que avec ma nouvelle famille que
j'ai fondée
ma femme aime la nature
[Musique]
je découvre les Canadiens
les vacances l'été et m'amène visiter
les parcs on va faire des campings on va
cueilli des citrouilles comme activité
de week-end imaginez si vous avez
cueilli des aubergines ou bien tirés de
manioc d'un voisin par de façon bénévole
et puis je vois que ça me fait rappeler
quelque chose
les vacances on est parti et les
d'origine chilienne on est parti au
Chili on visite de chili on peut faire
300 km juste pour aller admirer deux ou
trois volcans c'est bien beau c'est vrai
que oui ok on a fini on continue et je
vois je commence à comprendre un peu la
philosophie des Occidentaux comment ils
vivent et tout l'hiver c'est les cabanes
à sucre on est dans la nature les Jeux
d'hiver et tout
et là le déclic se passe-t-il mais oui
c'est donc ça c'est bien moi mais
j'étais déjà heureux en Côte d'Ivoire je
suis venu pour peaufiner ma vie pour
devenir riche comme ma mère de dire mais
je n'ai plus ce temps là mais je sais
que je suis dans Nature à tout j'ai été
avec moi donc pourquoi est-ce que je
vais rester ici maintenant que je les
comprends pourquoi je vais rester encore
moins 20 - 30 degrés non il faut que je
parte ma mère est en train de
vieillir et c'est là que je retourne en
Côte d'Ivoire et je fonce directement à
la plantation puis à laisser mon père et
je commence à vivre en hermie pour
mettre en place mon concept d'aucun se
moque de moi se disant mais on t'a
laissé une tentation au lieu de planter
tu joues les écolos et ça rigole je leur
dis vous savez il va arriver un jour où
ma seule journée
sera votre recette de 6 mois
et puis on est là je participe à un
premier salon du tourisme
et là je constate que vraiment je suis
dans un élément et je vais voir ma mère
dit maman c'est bon arrête de prier ne
demande plus rien dis Merci au Seigneur
moi j'ai trouvé ma voix tu es musulman
je n'arrive même plus à te dire l'argent
puis je t'en donne puis tu fais des
offrandes si je n'entonne pas mais oui
elle a envie de façon minimaliste dit
merci seulement au Seigneur
elle me dit qu'elle a compris
elle explique-moi c'est quoi ton
histoire je dis non moi j'ai décidé de
vous tourner dans la nature et je vais
vivre minimalement avec mes amis ceux
qui viennent me visiter cadeau la nature
et puis voilà à partir de là on s'en
sort et puis on les paye c'est ça j'ai
dit oui elle me dit OK et
le process avant où je participe à la
veille de ce salon est fait la
transition avec la nature c'est la
nature qui a toujours été ta mère moi je
suis fatigué j'ai compris que tu trouves
ta voix donc je rentre donc un révérence
j'ai pas le temps de pleurer je vais
pleurer maintenant mes amis sont là mes
compagnons comme je les appelle mes
clients et je suis déchaîné il faut que
le salon du tourisme marche il faut que
je lui montre que j'ai réussi et on
commence et finalement ma famille aussi
me rejoint et là je deviens plus fort et
à trois on est déchaîné d'un seul site
on passe à deux sites et en même temps
les journalistes s'affluent de partout
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe les
services d'état viennent me voir il faut
que vous ouvrez votre vos activités dans
les parcs réserve il faut que vous
fassiez ceci cela ok d'accord je n'ai
pas d'argent mais j'ai de l'argent aussi
riche dans la tête la nature me donne
tout et finalement d'un site nous sommes
passés à 8 sites aujourd'hui
sur le territoire ivoirien
et nous allons à l'international au
salon du tourisme de Paris de Madrid 12
je reviens encore et là je me rends
compte que c'est une science et c'est
quoi notre science un écosystème un
village une activité équatoristique donc
c'est ça notre concept quand vous venez
chez nous on vous fait balader dans la
nature de toute notre cœur à midi c'est
déguster de la nature on vous donne la
nourriture comme on le veut et
l'après-midi on vous fait profiter de la
nature et cette séance je trouve que on
vient on vient d'inventer quelque chose
que nous-même on ne comprenait pas et là
on a compris qu'on était la définition
étymologique même de l'écotourisme tel
que dit par l'Organisation mondiale du
tourisme et depuis ce jour nous recevons
des étudiants d'Europe qui viennent
étudier notre séance et voilà un peu
l'histoire de notre vie qu'est-ce qu'il
faut retenir à cela
il faut toujours à canaliser nos enfants
l'éducation de base compte sinon après
c'est la catastrophe l'histoire de ma
vie montre nos erreurs les erreurs de
nos papas de nos moments et comment
aussi se sont rattrapés aujourd'hui
c'est cette même nature qui m'a protégé
cette Mère Nature qui me nourrit et le
nom du domaine béni je l'ai donné en
honneur de mon père parce que j'estime
que Emma protégé de sa manière et au
lieu de dire un nom technique j'ai
préféré dire le domaine de mon père
sinon le domaine béni voilà pourquoi mon
concept s'appelle le domaine Bini donc
la nature me nourrit la nature me
protège et la nature aujourd'hui me
donne des sous je voudrais vous terminer
remercier ma femme et ma fille qui est
là puis on va faire que
[Applaudissements]
et aussi
et aussi les collègues du domaine unique
que je demande de se lever je les vois
pas dans la salle qui ont toujours été
là et qui ont compris le concept je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]